hot breath what and when we're talking
about aspirations like what are
what are your aspirations like what are
you hoping to
kind of achieve or excel through your
career now
um i don't know i would like to i would
like a level of commercial success i
would really like that i i
uh so um
hello
okay um girlfriend
oh okay yeah i i
thought you were talking to your
commercially successful self you're like
hello commercially successful self i'm
speaking to you
into existence
hilarious yeah and uh ryan says the same
thing that happened with music
garbage is on the radio
ah yeah i mean this commercial yeah the
side but like to you what is commercial
oh what are you oh
is there a cat in there like uh you know
i liked everything i was doing
i would like everything i'm i would like
uh everything that i'm doing to be even
on a higher level
obviously more um okay more commercial
success
but i also like different opportunities
like i would like to be on a show
i'm acting um i would like my podcast
to be what it is but even more way to
reach more people
i would like my comedy to you know reach
more people basically okay